would you date a guy that's a normal  nine okay would you date a guy  makes 40 000 per year and he's not hot  he's just like all right  average guy  average guy he has a little a little  weird he's like skinny you know little  beer belly  no  I take care of myself I'm in the gym  four to five times a week  um at whatever his salary is to me I  feel like I still want to be attracted  to the person that I'm with and forty  five thousand dollars well you could be  in the gym a gym membership is 20 a  month so if I'm again I had a kid a year  and a half ago I look damn good so it's  like I would want someone who takes care  of their body so the beer values were  kind where you lost me